You know the gist: 13 years in the
making, new technology, underwater,
yada yada yada — but what do the fans have
to say about Avatar: The Way of Water?
The second installment in the Avatar franchise
was released internationally on December 15th,
and those who rushed out to see the sequel
are now giving their reviews on Twitter.
James Cameron had a lot on his plate with
the movie, but the director certainly isn't
afraid of a challenge. There is at least
one more sequel on the way after The Way
of Water and possibly additional Avatar flicks
coming if everyone is happy with number two.
"The day we deliver Avatar 2, we'll just
start working on finishing Avatar 3."
So, are they happy? Well, those lucky enough to
have seen the film already certainly are, so there
is a lot to look forward to from Cameron in the
decade ahead. Let's get straight to it — finding
a negative reaction to Avatar: The Way of Water
is no easy feat. As one Twitter user posted:
Meanwhile, another said:
Some were going as far as to name Avatar:
The Way of Water the best movie
they'd ever seen. One tweet read:
Another moviegoer compared
the Avatar sequel to other
recent underwater flicks… and it's
clear one reigns supreme. They said:
It's hard to find someone who straight-up hated
Avatar: The Way of Water, but some people do
seem to take exception to the movie's lengthy
192-minute runtime. As one Twitter user posted:
Many Twitter users mentioned that the
film was a little too long in their posts,
but they often followed up with
a compliment. One user said:
Another wrote:
If three-hour films aren't a
problem for you, of course,
it seems like you won't have any
complaints about The Way of Water.
One person even claimed you won't notice
the three-hour-plus runtime, writing:
So, if you loved the first Avatar, you
should be thrilled with The Way of Water.
"I see you."
Twitter users have praised everything from
the movie's visuals to its 3D technology,
while pointing out that the story is more
complex than the first movie. Many pointed
out that the movie's themes and characters were
particularly compelling. As one Twitter user said:
There were plenty of tweets praising Zoe
Saldana's Neytiri in particular, which is
no surprise given she's a standout in the original
film. Jake and Neytiri's children also seem to be
a highlight — and, naturally, you should also
be ready to shed some tears. One poster said:
All in all, The Way of Water
appears to be worth the wait,
and moviegoers are likely to have one of
their best theater experiences of the year.